[Music]
here's Rob Kardashian on July 4th
hosting sweet photos with his little
daughter dream a literal picture-perfect
father but the next morning a different
story hi guys i'm lauren zima in case
you missed it on Wednesday July 5th Rob
went off on Instagram about dreams mom
blac chyna
he put up several apparent photos of
China's naked body which we will not be
showing in post after post Rob said
China was cheating on him that he'd
always been loyal to her and then
accused her of using drugs like cocaine
and ecstasy he repeatedly claimed that
he pays for her rent and cars and said
he's bought her thousands of dollars
worth of jewelry and even surgeries plus
he posted photos of a man who claimed a
China had cheated on him with about an
hour after Rob started posting the nude
photos were removed it's unclear if Rob
or Instagram took them down but he then
we uploaded them multiple times and
China responded on snapchat with claims
of her own saying Rob slept with other
women and accusing him of abuse
beat me up but I'm supposed to be quiet
because you're a Kardashian she then
deleted those snaps et has reached out
to both Rob and Chyna for comment head
to et online.com for the latest